>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Good morning.
How's everybody doing?
So my name's Pam Jackson.
I'm the director for
the Center for the Book
which is a really awesome place
in the Library of Congress.
And I'd like to welcome you
here to the Young Readers Center
which is another really,
really great place.
How many of you are
here for the first time?
Awesome. Thanks for being here.
So some of the hands
didn't get raised.
Some of you have been here before.
Yes? Or no.
You just weren't responding earlier.
Okay. Great.
All right.
So let me ask you where
are you guys from?
Harriet Tubman.
Where is that?
Washington, D.C. Columbia Heights.
Columbia Road.
Is it on Columbia Road in -- no?
Okay. Okay.
Great. So and then
what grades do we have?
What grades?
Is everybody third grade?
Welcome. What's wonderful
about third grade?
What do you like most
Recess. Well, just -- this is
the time you can shout it out.
So recess.
Recess. Two recess -- you
have two recesses every day?
Wow. And you get to take
on more responsibility.
Wow. That's awesome.
What's that?
One recess in the mornings?
Wednesdays.
Oh, on Wednesdays you only have one.
So what's today?
Today's not Wednesday so
you have two recesses today?
So on Wednesdays, you get
out at 3:15 and every what --
Monday through Saturday
you get out at 4:15?
You have extended day.
And do you really have school on
Saturday or did you just miss that?
You don't go Saturday?
You don't go to school
on Sundays either?
Wow. So you have Saturdays
and Sundays off?
Wow. Okay.
Great. All right.
So sometimes -- yeah,
so no school on Monday?
What is Monday?
Columbus Day.
Okay. So, you know, we're actually
open on Monday, Columbus Day.
So you can come back
and visit us again.
Bring your family, friends.
We're open Monday through
Friday 9:00 to 4:30.
On a day like Monday when you
don't have school, we're here.
So it's a great place to come.
There are a couple of rooms
fulls of books back there.
You can lounge around and hang
with your family and friends.
So we do invite you back for that.
And let me talk a little bit
about why we're here today.
So why are we here today?
Yes? Well, it's a field trip, yes.
To know about books.
Yes, ma'am?
So we can learn.
Okay. We can learn
different types of books.
Does anyone know what types of books
we're going to talk about today?
What type of book it is?
Who hasn't talked yet?
Yes? Chicken in the -- oh.
Is there something behind me?
Oh, yes. Chicken in the Kitchen.
And we have with us
somebody who's kind
of something to do with the book.
So what do you know about books?
Right. So -- yes, yes?
They can teach you some things
and in this book we might learn
about chickens and we might
learn about kitchens; right?
Yes, ma'am?
Go ahead, I'm sorry.
You can find adventures in books.
Absolutely.
What else?
You can learn about
lessons in books.
That's true.
Yes? Way in back.
You can find puzzles.
Yes, you can sometimes find puzzles.
So who makes books?
Yes, sir? Authors.
Right. And so we have the
author of this book with us.
It's really great.
She's going to do a
talk about her book,
a little bit about
the motivation for it,
and there's another person that's
with her that helped make the book.
Who do you think that is?
Illustrator.
What's an illustrator?
Yes? Draws the pictures.
That's right.
So we have the author and the
illustrator here with us for Chicken
in the Kitchen, Nnedi
Okorafor and Mehrdokht Amini.
And they will be with us shortly.
They're in the back
wrapping up something
and they'll be with us shortly.
So tell me have any of you --
raise your hands if
you've authored a book?
Or a story?
How about authored a story?
How about a story?
Okay. Great.
Hands down.
How many of you have authored
-- illustrated a story?
Okay. Great.
All right.
And how many of you --
so I asked this before.
Let me try it again.
How many of you have met other
authors and illustrators?
Yeah? Okay.
Great. Where were you
when you did that?
Were you here?
Did you meet him here?
No? Where were you?
School. So you've had authors and
illustrators come to school and talk
to you about their books?
That's really great.
All right.
So let me tell you a little bit more
about who's with us in the room.
So we have a great partner.
The Young Readers Center
partners with Everybody Wins DC
which is a really extraordinary
group of individuals
who help make this event possible.
They coordinated with your
teachers to bring you here
and they helped actually facilitate
the books that will be gifts
that you'll get to
take home with you.
And Jenny, wave your hand
is from Everybody Wins DC.
She's with us helping today.
So thank you for being here.
We also have with us
Brenda Randolph.
And Brenda is with Children's
Africana Book Awards.
Let me pause.
The Children Africana Book
Awards is the organization
that this book is actually --
we're celebrating the authors --
the author and the illustrator
as a winner of a special award.
And it's from that organization.
And Brenda Randolph is with us and
she's with the outreach council
of the African Studies Association.
Wave your hand, say hello.
Hi. Oh.
Oh, beautiful.
So when the -- so when books win
awards, that seal could be placed
on them to acknowledge that
they are award winners.
All right.
Great. And it looks like --
let me just check my notes here to
make sure I've covered everything.
So, yes, we're going to get
ready to actually meet the author
and the illustrator who are
available, ready to come join us.
So what do you guys know?
The author's going to talk a little
bit about the motivation of her book
and then she's going
to read the story.
So what do you guys know you should
be doing when she starts to do that?
Yes, ma'am?
Listening.
So what do we listen with?
Ears. Everybody do like this.
Make sure I know you
know where your ears are.
Okay. Great.
And so when we're listening
what are we not doing?
Talking. Okay.
What do we talk with?
Okay. Do like this.
Everybody clear.
So nothing's happening here.
All the action's here.
Yes, yes. Okay.
So let's welcome -- and --
and you're going to be excited
and it's going to be wonderful.
So you'll have questions
and we'll have time for that
so you can hold those until the end.
So while she's leading
-- while the author
and the illustrator are leading
we're going to be listening.
Do your ears again.
And then when they're finished, I'm
going to come back and say it's time
for questions and then
you'll be able to do what?
Talk, okay.
So no talking.
Talking. Ready?
Question? Well, no, it's
not so much a movie.
I think there will be some
pictures here that show you the --
a bigger version of the book
as she's going through it.
So it won't be a movie.
It's going to be way more
exciting than a movie.
All right.
Let's welcome our authors, Nnedi and
Mehrdokht, author and illustrator.
Come on.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: How are
we supposed to get through?
>> Pam Jackson: Oh, I guess
we -- let's make a path.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
Excuse me.
Thank you.
Okay. Good morning, everyone.
>> [group] Good morning.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Oh,
wonderful, wonderful.
So today I'm going to read you
my book, Chicken in the Kitchen.
And this was a book that -- a
story that I read or that I told
to my daughter for years
when she was little.
And the reason why I
told this story to her --
the reason why I made it up was
because my daughter just loved
chickens and she did not feel
that chickens got their due respect.
So -- so I came up with
a story about a chicken,
a very, very special chicken.
And over the years, I told her this
story and it kind of developed.
And then eventually
when the opportunity
to write a children's book came
along, this was the first story
that popped into my head.
And so it's wonderful to see
it realized in this book.
So I'm going to read this to you.
It's titled, Chicken in the Kitchen.
Okay.
Let me get comfortable here.
Okay. It was late at night.
A noise had woken Anyaugo.
She climbed out of bed and crept
quietly towards the kitchen.
[noise]
Oh, my, Anyaugo whispered.
What was she going to do?
There was a giant chicken
in the kitchen.
It was going to spoil the food her
mother and her aunties had cooked
for the New Yam Festival
the next day.
She had to do something.
[chicken noise] Said
the chicken happily.
The New Yam Festival marked the
beginning of the harvest season.
It was a time for being thankful,
dancing, seeing friends and family,
and of course eating lots of yams.
Anyaugo couldn't let the chicken
ruin the yam dishes in the fridge.
What was wrong with
it, Anyaugo wondered.
The chicken was causing
a lot of mischief.
Anyaugo wished she knew where
her friend the Wood Wit was.
He was a nature spirit.
He would know what to do.
Anyaugo tried to muster
up some courage.
I'm going to just tell it to leave.
Or maybe not.
It was time to get
help from the Wood Wit.
Where is it?
Anyaugo wondered.
The Wood Wit could travel
through anything made of wood.
It can be almost anything
-- anywhere.
Maybe it was playing
outside in the coconut trees.
If so, she would never
be able to find it.
Are you there, Anyaugo called.
There you are, Anyaugo said.
There you are, the Wood Wit said.
It laughed.
You have a chicken in your kitchen.
You want to -- and you
want to get rid of it.
How do you know?
Oh, I know everything that the
wood knows, the Wood Wit said.
Anyaugo didn't understand
what the Wood Wit meant
but that didn't matter.
The Wood Wit was always
saying odd things like that.
Will you help me?
Sure. I love being helpful.
It looks quite annoyed,
the Wood Wit said.
Whatever have you done to it?
I didn't do anything,
Anyaugo insisted.
How can I make it leave?
Ask it, the Wood Wit said.
But ask it in chickenese.
But I don't speak chickenese,
cried Anyaugo.
Say buck, buck, cluck,
the Wood Wit suggested.
But you have to say it just right.
It laughed out loud.
It laughed out -- it burst out
laughing, amused with itself.
Anyaugo lifted her chin,
clenched her fists and said hello.
The chicken flashed
the sunniest, shiniest,
sweetest smile Anyaugo
had ever seen.
Then the Wood Wit began to hum.
It sounded like three
voices and a soft drum beat.
It was with the sound of the drum
beat that Anyaugo understood.
How had she not guessed it?
This was more than a chicken.
Buck, buck, it said softly.
It was asking her to dance.
Later that night, when
Anyaugo finally went
to bed, she smiled to herself.
Her father had told her about
the powerful masquerade spirits
that came to participate
in the New Yam Festival.
Masquerades visited the
community during the festivals,
ceremonies, and events.
Some were spirits of the
elements, like the land and water.
Others were ancestors
returning to dance showing
that death was a natural
part of life.
This one must have come
for a midnight snack.
At the New Yam Festival the next
day, Anyaugo ate several yam dishes
and saw some of the biggest
yams she had ever seen.
But though she watched many
wonderful masquerades perform,
she did not see the chicken
masquerades amongst them until --
boom, boom, boom, -- The End.
[ Applause ]
So a little bit -- a
little bit more about --
about Chicken in the Kitchen.
Also masquerades.
I didn't talk much
about masquerades.
So masquerades are a very --
a deeply African tradition.
All parts of Africa have their
own masquerading traditions.
And masquerades are
basically, they are --
usually men who dress up
in these elaborate costumes
and these costumes are -- they are
symbols for the spirits or ancestors
or people who have passed and
they come out during ceremonies,
various ceremonies like
weddings, funerals,
parties, just celebrations.
And they can be scary.
They can be -- they can be utterly
terrifying; they can be funny;
they can just be weird; sometimes
they can just look like a big ball
of hay that dances
and shakes around.
It's fascinating.
So in this story, because my
daughter loved chickens so much
and I didn't feel like
chickens got enough respect,
I decided to also create a
masquerade chicken in this story.
So that's -- that's who you
encountered in this story.
So do we want to segue
into the drawing stuff?
Okay. Okay.
Go ahead.
>> Pam Jackson: Do you want to?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Well, okay.
No, you can go ahead.
>> Pam Jackson: Well, so how
many of you noticed other animals
in the slide presentation of
the book besides the chicken?
Raise your hand if you
noticed other animals.
And this is our talking part, right.
So you can shout out
what animals did you see.
I'll start over here.
A cat? What did you see?
You saw the chicken.
Yes, ma'am.
A bear. You think you saw a bear.
Okay. Yes, and what did you see?
A wood chuck?
Oh, wow. You guys are
very observant.
Really awesome.
What did you see?
Did you have one?
So -- okay.
Great. Thank you.
Yes, one last one.
Yes? Sorry, the what?
Oh, the Wood Wit, yes.
>> Nnedi Okorafor:
The Wood Wit, okay.
So -- can anyone -- okay.
So the Wood Wit is a creature that
lives in the -- it lives in wood.
It can move through wood and
it's a very smarmy, sarcastic,
tricky -- tricky character.
And it is Anyaugo's best
friend in this story.
Can anyone -- the Wood
Wit is here with us today.
Can anyone -- has anyone
seen the Wood Wit?
Has anyone?
Yes? Yes. Oh, look at the Wood Wit.
It's here.
Yes, the Wood Wit is
in all the walls
and the walls are made of wood.
So -- okay.
So yes. There were several
animals in the story; correct?
And Mehrdokht would like to --
is there any animal that
you guys would particular --
any character in the book that
you guys would particularly
like her to illustrate?
Because she drew all of the
-- everything in this book.
So is there anything
that you'd like to see?
Yes? The chicken?
Super chicken?
Is that -- would you
say that the chicken
in this story was a super chicken?
Yes, it was quite large.
Okay. No -- okay.
So you'd like to -- okay.
It was kind of special, yes, it was.
>> Pam Jackson: Let's see somebody
who hasn't shared with us yet.
Yeah. Let's get those hands up.
This is a time you get to talk so
who's going to -- ready for talking?
Yes, in the front.
Yes. The cat.
Yes. You love kittens.
Teeny tiny kitten.
And did that kitten
look like your kitten?
Nope. Your kitten's bigger.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: As
big as the chicken?
Okay. Making sure.
>> Pam Jackson: Yes, sir?
Your favorite was the chicken.
Okay. Great.
So what do you think?
You hear
[ Inaudible audience ]
>> Nnedi Okorafor: So there would be
the chicken, the cat, the Wood Wit.
>> Pam Jackson: Wood Wit.
The Wood Wit's right there.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Right.
Yeah, that's true.
That's true.
[ Inaudible ]
>> Mehrdokht Amini: When I
start sketching, the first thing
that I should think
about is this pad
as a proportion of the characters.
So which part of this chicken --
>> Pam Jackson: Just a reminder,
this is where we'll
switch back to using what?
And we'll listen as she talks
about how she's creating.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: Which
part of the chicken is this?
>> Pam Jackson: Raise your hand.
What is she doing -- what
is she sketching right now?
Yes, in the very back.
Feathers. Okay.
Does anybody have a question about
illustration as she's working?
Yes, sir?
What types of material does she use?
Like when she created
-- well, so let's start
with what she's using right now.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: Of course,
I always start sketching
with a pen and pad.
But then I use all
sorts of materials.
It depends on the book.
If I start painting and then I scan
them, take them to the computer
and work through digital software.
I don't know whether you cared
about software like Photoshop.
So kind of combination of drawing
and painting, making pictures and --
the whole thing to the
computer and work from there.
So I combine everything
-- all this stuff that --
>> Pam Jackson: Do you
need to see the chicken?
So you want to see the --
>> Mehrdokht Amini: You
want to see the chicken?
So this chicken might not be exactly
because I don't have the colors
and it might not be exactly.
>> Pam Jackson: So are you asking
if she's drawing from memory?
Okay. Yeah.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: Yeah.
I'm drawing from memory.
>> Pam Jackson: Who's
got other questions
about illustration perhaps?
Yes, yes, yes.
>> How does she make the Wood Wit?
>> Pam Jackson: How does
she make the Wood Wit?
>> Nnedi send me some pictures.
And they were so beautiful, so
powerful and I think they were kind
of -- got inspiration from looking
at the pictures from
the masquerades.
Remember you can't find him exactly
in those pictures but, you know,
the inspiration come from looking
at them and I just doodled and,
you know, I do the sketches and --
>> Pam Jackson: And so
this might be a good segue.
Is the Wood Wit your creation
or is this an African
culture creation that you've?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: It's -- the
Wood Wit is kind of a blend
between things that, you know,
that I would hear relatives talk
about especially when they
were talking about the forests.
And so they'd often talk about
spirits in the forest and especially
in the wood, in the trees.
And so I would think about those and
then the Wood Wit came from that.
And the Wood Wit's personality,
you know, very annoying,
tricky personality, I guess
I kind of came up with that.
Just fun, yeah, yeah.
>> Pam Jackson: And we'll do --
do you have another
mike for over there?
Okay. Yes?
Question?
>> I was going to say how does
she come up with these creations?
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
Is that for the author
or the illustrator?
The author.
How do you -- the illustrator?
Okay. So the question is how do
you come up with the creations?
>> Mehrdokht Amini:
Well, it's the story.
[inaudible] Story that
give me ideas.
I read the story many, many times.
And then you know I've
never been to Nigeria.
I never had an Nigerien friend
so I needed to do research.
And research on the culture
and the art, the people.
And then -- well I, yeah.
As I said I always have
my pad with me and pen
and I do sketching all the time.
So through those sketches, there
by little comes the characters.
And Nnedi was there to help me
and, you know, always advise me
on the colors that, you know --
>> Nnedi Okorafor:
The feet, the feet,
I know we talked a
lot about the feet.
>> Mehrdokht Amini:
The feet, the feet.
Nnedi might change things as we go.
>> Pam Jackson: So just
a quick question there.
Do the chickens in Nigeria look
different than the chickens
that we might have seen here?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: That's
an interesting question
and I was always fascinated by
the chickens that I would -- Okay.
So I was born and raised here
in the United States and then
from a young age my parents
would take my siblings and I back
to Nigeria to meet with family.
Both of my parents are from Nigeria.
So we would meet with family
and we'd stay especially
in the villages, the
smaller more rural areas
where especially my
father had grown up.
And whenever we would go
there would be chickens,
just free range chickens
that are just free to do --
go wherever they want, wherever
they please, all over the village.
And they would always come
back to their homes at night.
So in the morning you'd see
them come out, scratch around,
making their chicken
sounds, their bucking
and clucking and all of that.
And then they would walk into
-- at some point in the day,
they would just walk into the forest
and you never knew
where they would go.
And then they'd come
back in the evening.
So I was always fascinated by this.
And also one thing I noticed about
the difference between the chickens
that I would see here in the
United States versus over there,
the chickens here would
be more of the --
they'd be white; they'd
be one color;
they'd be more domesticated
and fatter.
And the ones that I would
encounter were not free range.
So those are the chickens
that I would see here.
And in Nigeria they were free
range and they were always --
they were skinnier and
they had longer legs.
And they're -- and when
you would eat them,
yeah, we would eat them, yes.
The meat was tougher and it
was chewier and more flavorful
which I don't -- I know that's
not really part of the story here
because we're dealing with
living chickens but yeah,
I guess that would be --
that would be the difference
that they seemed freer and
had a chance to just be birds
and have personalities and
life and all of that, so, yeah.
That would be the difference.
>> Pam Jackson: All right.
So I've got one question here.
Yes, sir?
>> How did you both come together?
>> Pam Jackson: How
did the two, the author
and the illustrator come together?
Oh, great question.
How did you come together?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Did
you want to answer that?
>> Mehrdokht Amini:
Actually it's the first time
that Nnedi and I see each other
>> Nnedi Okorafor: In person.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: In person.
Maybe did we send e-mails?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
We exchanged a lot.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: But, you
know, it's through internet.
I live in UK.
She lives in U.S. so it
was impossible for us
to meet each other in person.
But we kept in touch
through e-mails and yeah.
She was there for me
whenever I needed her help.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yes.
And vice versa.
And our publisher also
brought us, introduced us.
And so then we worked
together from there.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
Who knows what the publish
-- what's a publisher?
What's a publisher?
Yes, sir? What's a publisher?
>> A publisher is someone
that when an author
and an illustrator finish the story,
it is someone that finishes
all the stuff that they work
and makes it public so
everybody can see it.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
So you want to add -- so great.
Great answer.
You want to add to
that a little bit?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
Well, yes, very excellent question.
The publisher would take the story
that we brought together
and make it into a book.
And then put it out there
for other people to get
and read and all of that.
So the publisher is, I guess, the
entity that brings the author's work
to -- into a packaged thing.
If that makes sense.
That's a very simplified
way of putting it, yes.
>> Pam Jackson: All right.
Great. So there's a question here.
I'm going to just come this way.
Yes?
>> How tall is the chicken?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Literally?
That's a great question.
How tall do you think
the chicken is?
>> I think it would be --
>> Nnedi Okorafor: 8 feet?
Who else? 4 feet tall?
Ten? The size of you?
All of your answers are correct.
The chicken can be
whatever size it wants to be
because it is a powerful,
masquerade spirit and so
at some points it can be 4 feet.
I think if it were -- if it
chose the size that it liked
to be the most often,
I'd say 10 feet.
Yeah. It's a big chicken.
>> Pam Jackson: How many of you
have seen a 10-foot chicken?
Raise your hand?
Oh, wow. Okay.
Great.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Excellent.
>> Pam Jackson: Really awesome.
Okay. So do we want to -- do you
want to say more about what you?
So hang on.
Shh. Okay.
So we're going to ask for your ears.
Ears on, ears on again.
Because the drawing
has been finished.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: Yeah.
Just to show you how
I start my work.
I mean I start on the composition,
do lots of composition sketching.
[Inaudible] sketching
on composition.
And then I decide then
which one works best.
I thought maybe.
Do we have time to do
another sketching and then
at the same time we'll
talk with the children.
May be they could give me a name
of an animal and then I sketch
and then you would give me marks
based on how good I've done.
I might not be able to do it.
It's a very risky thing on my part.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: Unicorn?
Unicorn is not that difficult.
Yes? Baby chickens?
Do baby chickens.
Another -- how about monkey?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Okay.
So we've got -- we've
got three choices.
We've got a unicorn,
a chick, and a monkey.
Raise your hand if you
want to do the unicorn.
Okay.
>> Pam Jackson: One, two, three,
four, five votes for that.
Six, seven, sorry.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Raise your
hand if you want to do the monkey.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: You
only get to vote once.
>> Pam Jackson: Monkey.
One. One, two, three,
four, five, six.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Okay.
Raise your hand if you
want to do the chick.
>> Pam Jackson: Uh-oh.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Okay.
That's the chick.
>> Pam Jackson: One, two,
three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten, 11.
All right.
>> Pam Jackson: So wait.
I'm sorry.
I wasn't listening.
So what's it -- she just drew a
chicken and now she's drawing chick.
What's the difference?
Wait, wait, wait.
Way in the back.
Hold on. Hold on.
Let me -- I really -- you guys are
going to have to help me with this.
What's the difference?
>> A chick is smaller
and a chicken is bigger.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
A chicken is -- a chick is
smaller and the chicken is bigger.
[ Inaudible ]
Is ten good?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: We're
all over the place here.
We're just -- we're
all over the place.
>> Pam Jackson: Oh, okay.
Wait. Shh.
And were you going to
add to the difference
between a chick and a chicken.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Okay.
>> Pam Jackson: Yes?
No?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Big eyes.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
Hang on. Shhh.
Question.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah, okay.
Wait, no. Is this eagle or owl?
>> Pam Jackson: Need bigger eyes?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Big round eyes.
>> Pam Jackson: Smaller head.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
We're doing eagle.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
So what's the difference
between an eagle and a chicken?
Eagle and a chicken?
Hang on one second.
Yes?
>> A chicken is a -- I
mean an eagle is a predator
and a chicken is not a predator.
>> Pam Jackson: Whoa.
Eagle is a predator
and a chicken is not.
Okay. But then I guess my
question is what's a predator?
Okay, yes.
Help me out.
>> Meat eater.
>> Pam Jackson: A predator
is a meat eater.
So an eagle is a meat
eater and a chicken is not.
Are you going to help
me out with this?
>> And the chicken is a
plant eater or I mean --
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
Good question.
Is the chicken a plant eater?
What do chickens eat?
>> Nnedi Okorafor:
That's a good question.
>> Pam Jackson: Wait a minute.
Did I hear cheese?
Okay. Chickens eat worms.
Raise your hand if
you agree with that.
But who's the chicken
expert in the room?
I don't know.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Close.
That's cute.
Bugs, seeds.
You know -- you do know that
chickens also eat fruit.
Did you know that?
They'll eat watermelon.
If you put watermelon rinds,
they will eat that too.
So yeah. Chickens -- chickens
will eat a lot of things.
>> Pam Jackson: So there's
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
They'll eat seeds, small
worms, bugs, fruit.
Yeah. So I think they eat worms
but I've never seen one eat worms.
They might.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
So there's one other big
difference that I heard
for chickens versus eagles.
There's one big difference that
I know that I did not yet hear.
So what's another difference
between the chicken and the eagle?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Oh, yeah.
The obvious.
>> Pam Jackson: Oh, wait.
I have a hand.
Somebody we haven't heard from yet.
Yes, ma'am?
>> Um, an eagle can fly
and a chicken can't.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yes.
>> Pam Jackson: So how many
of you guys heard that?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yes.
>> Pam Jackson: Hang on one sec.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Who -- okay.
So who heard her answer
that the biggest --
the biggest difference between
a chicken and an eagle is
that the chicken cannot fly and the
eagle is an expert flyer; correct?
So everyone knows that
chickens can't fly.
Does anyone know why
chickens can't fly?
I'd love to hear this answer.
>> Pam Jackson: You ready?
Hang on. Hang on.
Why can chickens not fly?
>> I think that chickens cannot fly
because they don't
have hollow bones.
>> Pam Jackson: They
don't have hollow bones.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: They
do have hollow bones.
And you know you're talking
about ostriches though.
Because ostriches have very
heavy bones and very dense bones.
And it's because they don't fly --
they're actually land animals
so they run very, very fast.
So -- so no, but chickens
do have hollow bones.
They just I believe evolutionary
-- like in terms of evolution,
they just didn't develop
the ability to fly.
And there are other
flightless birds.
Another one that I -- the first one
that pops into my head, penguins.
The doo-doo which doesn't
exist any more.
There's a parrot -- there's a
flightless parrot in New Zealand.
And there are other
flightless birds.
But some birds just don't
develop the ability to fly
because maybe they're -- where
their habitat does not -- is not --
makes it so that they
don't need to fly.
But that might be completely wrong.
>> Pam Jackson: And --
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
>> Pam Jackson: Go ahead.
I just noticed something though.
I noticed that there's this book
here that looks like your book
but it doesn't say
what your book says.
What? Oh, how many
of you speak Spanish?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Oh, nice.
Excellent.
>> Pam Jackson: Wow.
That's awesome.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: So is this -- for
those of you who do speak Spanish,
I speak more French than Spanish,
but is this a direct translation
of Chicken in the Kitchen.
It is? Good.
Good. Thank you.
>> Mehrdokht Amini: It's not exactly
-- it's more an owl than an eagle.
>> Pam Jackson: How
many of you think
that this is the eagle
that you requested?
How many of you think
of it as something else?
[ Group discussion ]
>> Nnedi Okorafor: They were
going to ask to draw the Wood Wit.
It's neither.
Okay. While she's drawing that,
I have a question for you all.
Okay. So if you were in Anyaugo's
position where you woke up one night
and your parents are
asleep, everyone's asleep.
And you hear some noise in there.
And you go and look in the kitchen
and you see a giant
chicken, what would you do?
Someone who has not answered.
Yeah.
>> Pam Jackson: In the back.
Way in the back.
Roger.
What would you do?
You wake up in the
middle of the night;
the chicken's in your kitchen.
What are you going to do?
>> Uh --
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Wait.
Everyone listen to --
>> I'll ask my mom.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: -- I
think his name is Robert
>> And I'll actually eat him.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Let's see.
Or Roger, thank you.
>> Pam Jackson: Say it
again so everybody can hear.
>> I don't know.
>> Pam Jackson: I heard something
about your mom and eating it.
>> Yeah. I'll eat it.
>> Pam Jackson: How many go
for the I'm going to eat it.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Oh my goodness.
>> Pam Jackson: How many are going
to go for I'm telling my mom?
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Tell your mom.
>> Pam Jackson: Not so many.
Thank you, Roger.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Even if
you see a beautiful chicken
or like a beautiful bird in your
kitchen, would you want to eat it?
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Well, first --
>> Pam Jackson: Did
you want to ask them --
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
This is if you woke up in the middle
of the night and the kitchen --
the chicken was in your
kitchen, whatcha going to do?
>> I would grab a rope.
Jump on the kitchen's
back and say, yee haw.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Oh my gosh.
>> Pam Jackson: So she's
going to lasso the chicken.
>> Going to scream to
my mom and wake her up.
>> Pam Jackson: Scream
to mom, wake her up.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Good answer.
Good answer.
>> I'm going to freak out.
>> Pam Jackson: She's
just going to freak out.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yeah.
That's a good answer too.
>> Pam Jackson: Okay.
Look. Wait.
We have the Wood Wit.
>> Nnedi Okorafor: Yes.
[applause] Good.
Well done.
>> Pam Jackson: Hang on one sec.
What were you going to say?
>> I was going to say --
>> Listen.
>> I was going to say I would kick
the chicken out of the window.
>> Pam Jackson: Oh, he's going to
kick the chicken out the window.
Okay.
So I want everybody -- zero.
Was it at zero?
>> Zero.
>> Pam Jackson: Zero?
So here's the Wood Wit.
And now we're going to
evaluate the new version.
Scale of 1 to -- we're not
going to evaluate the Wood Wit.
We're just going to give
her a round of applause.
[ Applause ]
So -- thank you all.
So we would like to say thank you so
much for you all being here and we'd
like to thank our author and
illustrator for sharing themselves,
their work, and their talent.
It's been a great opportunity to
be with you, to hear your story,
and learn about -- a little bit
more about Nigerian culture.
And to learn about ten foot
sized chickens has been really --
I'm going to take that away.
Yes, ma'am?
>> [Group] Thank you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.